Last year IBM and Telefonica teamed up to
create the first version of Cloud Garden,
a revolutionary platform that allows large
enterprises and government bodies
to accelerate their digital transformation.
This was doneusing the latest technologies
in containers, artificial intelligence and blockchain.
Now weare bringing another partner on board
to take another major leap forward.
We are incorporatingRed Hat via its OpenShift platform
which will make moving to containers an even simpler task.
Cloud Garden's future is and must be multi-cloud.
Our customers need to use the cloud that
best matches their use cases,
which vary depending on parameters
such as security,compliance, cost, and proximity to the process.
A shift towards container environments is the only effective way of making this transfer of loads.
It enables us to create much more
resilient open architectures at aneven lower cost.
With Cloud Garden,we take care of the platform so that you, the customers,
only haveto concern yourselves with the really important aspect of the business application
toensure effective transformation within companies.
We can do this because of the high level of
integration with other telephone services
and, above all, because of
integration with communications.
We are backed in this service by major
partners such as IBM and Red Hat,
whose Cloud Pak and OpenShift technologies enable
us to help customers take that step.
Cloud Garden is Telefonica's platform for transforming
your applications using open architecture.